stéphanie a connu au cours de sa vie
professionnelle deux types de
discrimination la première raciste
contre sa couleur de peau Stéphanie
Constantin souvent et s'attendait à des
profils plutôt caucasiens de par la
consommation de mon prénom et de mon nom
de famille effectivement j'ai pu voir
par le passé des yeux qui
s'équarquillaient la deuxième allons
contre de ses cheveux un exemple qui a
fait les gros titres en 2022 après avoir
été de traité de connards chauves par
son ancien employeur un électricien a
porté plainte devant la Cour il a
expliqué que c'est des deux mots c'est
le commentaire sur son apparence
capillaire plus que l'insulte qu'il
avait blessé les trois juges eux-mêmes
chauves il y aura accordé des indemnités
en estimant que ce qualificatif était
directement lié à son sexe et relevé
donc du harcèlement sexuel rien pour
l'autre mot c'est pour bannir de
l'univers professionnel ce type de
remarqué de monde que ce député vient de
déposer une très sérieuse proposition de
loi visant à reconnaître et à
sanctionner la discrimination capillaire
et pour trouver le caractère systémique
de ces discriminations il s'est basé sur
deux études faites aux États-Unis et au
Royaume-Uni
doivent changer leur coupe de cheveux
lorsqu'elles vend un entretien
d'embauche et cela toujours selon la
même étude car elles sont 2,5 fois plus
susceptibles d'être perçu comme nom
professionnel j'ai commencé à perdre mes
cheveux tellement plus jeune âge de le
dire afin d'adolescence et cette offre
c'est une forme de traumatisme qui est
lié à l'estime de soi la confiance en
soi aussi et puis chemin faisant au gré
des rencontres au gré des personnes qui
arrivent à vous rassurer au gré aussi du
fait que l'on puisse accepter tel que
l'on est je crois qu'on arrive à
transcender cet aspect là et puis comme
je vous le disais à chaque cheveux
perdus c'est honnête qu'on a rendu
heureux moi j'adore quand vous vous
touchez
la dernière fois donc
voilà du tactile voilà
[Musique]
droit depuis sage dans le métier
selon une étude de la Fondation
canadienne pour la recherche capillaire
les chauves ont ta compétence égale un
tiers de chances en moins de décrocher
un emploi que les autres une
discrimination accompagnée par des
craintes la plus grande appréhension de
9 Français sur 10 concernant leur
physique et la calvitie comme ça on va
dire une à deux fois par semaine ça
dépend de semaine ça dépend des périodes
quand j'ai le temps je mets comme ça
avec plaisir mais tu peux vous toucher
aussi
bien sûr juste envie feu vert
très agréable c'est très agréable allez
on va tous le toucher
ici notre confrère est chauve naissant
il va pencher son crâne il ne peut pas
encore accéder au gras de chauve
couronnées parce qu'il a encore trop de
peu ici donc il doit être patient et
moyennant la patience et les années ben
peut-être qu'il arrivera à monter de
grade puis vous avez un chauffe couronné
ici sans tricher les cheveux sont partis
sur le sommet et reste sur le côté et
puis alors notre idéal à tous c'est de
venir chauffe intégrale comme notre cher
ami Ernst
le bon goût du pain au chocolat français
regardez on dit chocolat
[Musique]
ine
anti chocolatine Adeline dans la série
du rêve ils sont pourtant nombreux à
venir le chercher quand il se rendent
dans la boulangerie familiale de cette
internaute et pour cause c'est l'un des
lieux iconiques de la série Émilie in
Paris mais une fois sur place pour
certains c'est la déception et ils le
font savoir dans leurs commentaires
quant à ceux qui estiment avoir mangé le
pire croissant de la capitale la fille
du propriétaire a un message pour eux
c'est juste donner des preuves pour
montrer que vous avez pas parlé
finalement
de l'huile
c'est de l'huile dans du sucre et le
makrout c'est de l'huile dans de l'huile
qui est dans du sucre voilà si vous
cherchez le diabète
que mon petit frère m'a offert c'est le
caleçon monsieur président parce que
quand j'étais à quand j'étais à l'école
j'étais président du BDE
en plus c'est sur les fesses donc j'ai
peut-être pas me désapper au crayon mon
Dieu ah moi je suis quelqu'un qui
surprend je peux vous dire
une quiche pour célébrer le couronnement
de Charles III le 6 mai prochain la
famille royale dévoile sur les réseaux
sociaux la recette officielle que les
Britanniques sont invités à réaliser
pour l'occasion un plat végétarien à
base d'épinard de fèves et d'estragon
les sujets de Sa Majesté semblant en
croire les commentaires en revanche côté
français on dénonce la présence de
manque mais également de fromage râpé on
savait déjà que ce n'était pas les rois
de la gastronomie ironise certains le
haut Hélène mon premier est une boisson
mon deuxième est une boisson et mon tout
ça fait plein de moutons
[Musique]
sur la planète et à l'équivalent ça se
passe tout au nord
au nord de la France
à Dunkerque
un acte officiel mais avec une portée et
des sanctions seulement symboliques
obligation dans ton nez tous les mardis
matins pendant le marché une chanson à
boire afin d'encourager la consommation
des vins locaux ce qui amuse les
habitants même si les risques de se
faire confisquer tous leurs vins qui ne
sont pas produits dans la commune en cas
de non-respect de cette règle c'est
surtout très léger je pense que les gens
ne comprendront c'est vraiment une
boutade moi je personne ne l'a vu venir
[Musique]
salut les loups allez on vous embrasse
salut c'est le matin salut François